the Pentagon is ending its vaccine
mandate for servicemen after the House
GOP makes them do it the dod is ending
it because house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
forced an end to the program last month
with the new National Defense
authorization act which is the annual
defense policy and spending bill that
passed and so it's not that the Pentagon
just decided out of the goodness of its
heart it's not that Mark milley there
was able to put down the ibram candy was
able to put down genderqueer by Maya
kobabi and and went in and scrubbed all
the purple out of his hair got rid of
some of his piercings and his pride
flags and said you know what now all of
a sudden we're not going to make you
take the fauciology that's not what
happened what happened was the House GOP
forced the pentagon's hand what happened
was the GOP used political power for
good effects